اعلن الجيش السوداني موافقه قائده عبد
الفتاح البرهان بشكل مبدئي على مبادره من
منظمه الايجاد تضمنت مقترحات لحل الازمه
الحاليه في حين لم يصدر اي تعليق من الدعم
السريع وبحسب بيان الجيش السوداني فان
المقترحات تتضمن تمديد الهدنه 72 ساعه كما
قال البيان ان مبادره الايجاد تشمل افاده
ممثلين عن القوات المسلحه والميليشيا
المتمرده الى جوبا للتفاوض
وفي حديث للجزيره خارجيه جنوب السودان
دينقداو اي حوار مباشر بين البرهان
واحميطي في الوقت الراهن وعزى ذلك الى
ظروف الحرب
الرئيس طلب محادثات مباشره بين الرئيس
البرهان وحميتي هذا قد لا يحدث اثناء
الحرب لكن ممثليهما يمكنهم اجراؤها وهذا
يمكن ان يحدث داخل السودان او في منطقه
مقبوله للطرفين